And so the enemy pilot dies the death
that his stupidity deserved.
If you must charge towards an
aircraft, do it at an angle.
Greetings all, I'm Nicholas Moran.
I commissioned as an
armor officer for M1 tanks
and then converted to M3 Bradleys.
These days, I work as a
civilian vehicle historian,
primarily for World of Tanks.
I'm back again to rate tank battles
on movies and TV and
judge how real they are.
The Ripsaw, which was
basically a tracked toy
for people to drive around in,
looks just like it does in the movie here.
It's because it had such lightweight
and such a high-powered weight ratio,
the thing is incredibly
fast and incredibly nimble,
which of course, attracts the
attention of the military,
well, hang on a second.
We've got this vehicle
that can go anywhere
really, really quickly. Can
we do something with it?
But the variant that the
Army has been looking at
of late is actually a
robotic combat vehicle.
I believe it's the RCVM,
and it's being plugged
as the M5, and on the top,
much like is shown in the clip,
is a remote weapon station.
He's driving on ice, and those
don't look like ice tracks.
Believe it or not, there's
actually ways you can get
more grip on a tracked vehicle on ice.
It's anything from snow chains,
those used in World War II,
to these days, you can have grousers
that you knock out a few track pads,
and you put basically
cleats into the track.
This thing is going quite fast
doing its various maneuvers
on ice, and that's
questionable in this context.
I can think of no reason
except for an accession to plot
why a tank would have a
grappling hook attached to it.
The Lambo at the point
that they connect is
basically underwater, and
that provides more drag
than this thing can haul.
Well, that's your point for realism.
The door came off instead of
the Lambo getting pulled out.
I'm going to be generous.
I'm going to give it one
point because it has tracks.
And I'm going to give it one point
because it pulled the door
instead of the whole Lambo,
so I'm going to give it a two.
So you will have seen the
Americans had somebody standing
on the back firing the caliber .50.
The caliber .50 was originally
put onto American vehicles
as an anti-aircraft weapon.
And the reason that it's
on that external mount
at the back is that it's a
lot easier to aim upwards
if you're standing on the
back deck and then aiming up,
as opposed to trying to stick
your head out of the hatch
and maybe put it down from the side
and you're not even
able to use the sights.
Shermans!
One of the things Sherman was
very good at was showing up
when you needed a tank,
and they tended not to go
around in ones and twos.
They tended to go around in fives and 17s.
Yeah, sure, on a tank-on-tank duel,
it wasn't necessarily the best.
For an infantryman that's
under heavy attack,
he doesn't care if the best
tank in the world shows up,
as long as the tank which
shows up a) actually arrives,
and b) is good enough to deal
with whatever the
infantryman's problem is.
So you'll notice that the
Germans don't actually have
any tanks, which was a
problem that the Germans had
in World War II, is that their
industry simply wasn't up
to the levels of American or Russian.
So what we have here are a lot
of assault guns and tank destroyers.
It looks like a Marder there,
or at least a representation
of one, a Sturmgeschütz,
which is an assault gun,
and a Jagdpanther.
The Jagdpanther is the only
one that is the serious threat
to an allied vehicle.
Why didn't the Jagdpanther
just sit there and place
its extremely tough frontal
armor to the Shermans?
Well, you could do that,
but then you were probably now
placing your weak flank armor
to the American infantry, who are equipped
in the scene with bazookas,
anti-tank rocket launchers.
The Germans now are flanked,
and so very sensibly,
they immediately abandon the
attack and start falling back.
This is as good as you're going to get
on celluloid or on digits.
If there is ever going to be a 10
for "rate a tank battle,"
this is probably it.
The tanks represent Saint-Chamond.
There's only one that exists in the world.
It's at the French national
tank museum in Saumur.
Now, the cognoscenti will look
at the road wheels on that
and realize that the vehicle is based off
a BMP or an MT-LB, which are
Soviet Cold War vehicles.
By this point in the war, we're talking
towards the end of 1918, the
Germans are very familiar
with tanks, but you'll still
want to shoot them anyway
for a couple of reasons.
One is if the tanks are
accompanying infantry,
well, you're going to have
an effect on the infantry
and maybe suppress them to the point
that the tanks are going
to advance on their own.
Secondly, the tanks were not
the most robust at the time.
There was a problem known
as splash, especially when
once the tankers would actually
wear a type of chain mail
in front of their face with
goggles to stop the pieces
of bullet coming in the gaps in the armor.
Finally, it's psychological.
It makes you feel a lot better
to actually do something,
even if it's a gesture of futility.
The early tank guns for
World War I would have
generally either been
converted artillery pieces
or, quite often, naval guns.
The big problem you're going to have
with getting them close
is called depression.
So there is a stop as to how
far down the gun will depress,
and that determines how close you can get
to the enemy trench before you
can have to stop engaging it.
To this date, trench-crossing
ability in terms of meters,
how many meters of
trench you can cross, is
still a criterion.
The idea of can you cross
it without collapsing it,
well, that depends if you
want to collapse it or not.
So even as late as the Iraq campaigns,
a tank would go up to
fortified enemy position,
turn on the spot, and
bury the people inside.
And it's one of those unfortunate
realities of basically,
tanks have many ways of killing you,
and the tracks are one of them.
You'd think today a hand grenade
isn't going to do very much.
The tracks on the
Saint-Chamond were basically
for my whole tractor, so
they weren't as battle-proof
as a modern vehicle would be.
In fact, the armor on
this is so thin that a lot
of heavy bullets, they even
developed rifle bullets
with an armor-piercing core could go
through these early tanks.
This is an eight and a half, maybe nine.
I could quibble a few things,
but it generally gets the concept across.
Oh, goody.
So Rambo has gotten into his,
I'm going to call it a T-72.
It's not actually,
but the helicopter here represents a Hind.
I think it's actually
a Puma, but the Hind,
the Mi-24, was a gunship
that still actually has
a troop-carrying capacity,
as well as carrying a lot
of rockets and missiles
and being heavily armored.
It's basically a flying tank,
for lack of a better term.
So hang on, is he
driving, or is he gunning?
There's only one tank that I can think of
that is fully combat-capable
with one crewman,
and that is the Swedish Strv 103,
commonly known as the S-tank.
The driver functions
as the gunner as well,
and this is why you're supposed to go
with anti-aircraft vehicles
in company with you,
because their job is to defend
you against air threats.
So our enemy is in an attack
helicopter, a gunship,
and it's got missiles on the
tips, AT-2 Swatters probably,
that are effective from
several kilometers away.
And instead, he's firing unguided rockets
at the front of the Rambo tank.
Why doesn't he just fly
around the back and shoot
the rockets into the engine
deck or the rear turret,
or you know, some place
that'll actually cause damage?
And so the enemy pilot dies the death
that his stupidity deserved.
Officially, if you must
charge towards an aircraft,
do it at an angle.
He has to not only aim for lead,
but also the change in
distance at the same time.
Whereas if you're
charging straight at him,
you're simplifying the problem
for the aircraft that's coming at you.
He doesn't need to worry about aiming.
It has a tank, so I'll give it a one.
Fire.
The premise of an ambush
in an urban setting by
armor is not unheard of,
but the idea of armor
operating in an urban setting
without infantry support
is normally questionable.
Panthers are not well suited
for close-range fighting.
They really would excel
on the Eastern Front,
well, the steppes of Ukraine, for example,
nice long lines of fire.
That said, they can get
away with it in this context
because they know that
the enemy is a single tank
with no infantry.
Oh look, you're going
through a building again,
except this time he's
done one thing right.
He's got the turret
traversed over the rear.
I'd mentioned before, you don't want to go
through a building if you can avoid it.
In this case, I guess they couldn't,
because they're getting shot at.
And if you are going to go
through, spin your turret over,
and you'll keep yourself safe.
And what you can see here,
the T-34-85 has a very
neat traverse handle,
so it performs two functions.
In this case, you can see
he has it in manual mode,
cranking around, as
opposed to electric mode,
which, you simply flip
the handle 90 degrees.
However, maybe the gunner
just doesn't know this,
because in the movie,
this was a found tank.
Even myself, when I got into
a T-34-85 for the first time,
and trying to see where is
the second control handle,
I can't find it.
This is quite feasible.
When faced with the Panther
in this close range,
T-34 crew now has a choice.
It can either run away, or
it can attempt to engage.
Now, I would probably agree
with the 34 crew on this for two reasons.
One, the Panther was looking
the wrong way entirely.
And the other thing is Panthers
are not the easiest thing
in the world to kill,
unless you can get around
the side or behind them.
And in this case, they're
already behind them,
so why not engage?
But the only thing I might have
done differently was back up
two or three tank lengths
and aim the gun into the engine deck.
That would be a more guaranteed kill
than trying to aim for the turret ring.
So the explosion was
actually a little bit faster
than what would really happen.
Generally speaking, when a
tank is hit, it takes a couple
of seconds, and those are
your couple of seconds
that is the difference
between life and death
when you're getting out of a vehicle.
Although in reality, the
net-effect difference
to the crew is academic.
They're basically toast.
In this context, I don't
know, maybe a seven.
The movie is set about the
time of the Yemeni civil war.
It's actually kind of still ongoing.
The film was made in Morocco,
hence, you have the M60s and
the T-72s. So the exact nature
of the tanks that you get in
Yemen isn't entirely there,
but hey, for movie purposes,
it gets the point across.
Certainly there are Western
and Eastern tanks in the area.
Tank Alpha, attack from the right!
Hong Xu!
Turn 20 degrees left, hurry!
So what I have here is
a VIC-1 CVC, combat
vehicle crewman, helmet.
And the reason you would
want to wear a helmet
even if you're inside
the tank is quite simply,
you're being thrown around,
and there's a lot of sharp,
pointy things sticking out at you
that as you're being thrown around,
you don't want to hurt your head.
And of course, you also
have the dust goggles,
because the tanks are throwing
a lot of dust up at you.
You don't have a windshield.
If you're doing 40 miles an hour,
there's still enough
wind that you'll notice,
so you wear a set of goggles, as well.
It's good to see armor actually work.
So what has happened there is a round hit
explosive reactive armor. So
those bricks that you see,
and what they generally consist of,
though this is a gross oversimplification,
is a couple of pieces of metal sandwiching
a piece of explosive, and
that when a round hits it,
it explodes and disrupt or destabilize it
to the extent that the main
armor belt behind can stop it.
Turn right!
Nan Xia, get ready!
Fire!
You got a couple of problems.
Firstly, if the entire
turret system is off line,
then the tank is still
rocking a little bit.
It may not look it much, but
it's going to be rocking enough
that he cannot hip-shoot
a 125 on a point target
like a tank like that.
Secondly, he literally is hip-shooting,
and he's eyeballing it.
I don't see why he couldn't
still be using the gunsight.
He can then pull the trigger himself.
Sandstorms do happen.
In the 2003 invasion
of Iraq, there was one
that basically shut down the
war for a couple of days.
Well, your big problem with a
sandstorm is the air filters.
So the sand is going to
get into your air filters
and clog them up very quickly.
However, in this context,
I don't think they had
a heck of a lot of choice,
because being chased
by a platoon of M60s,
they were probably going to die anyway,
so why not make for the
sandstorm and hope for the best?
So I think seven's probably fair.
I'm not even sure where to start.
I'm trying to think of any
reasonable military context
that this vehicle could exist in.
The US Army has a vehicle, the
M1117, which is a derivative
of the old LAV-100s from Vietnam.
It's basically a huge, armored 4-by-4
with a gun turret on the
top for military police use.
I'm sure they wouldn't
mind something like this.
So generally speaking, convoys,
just because of the nature
of roads, you tend to be in
column instead of line abreast
like in the shot here.
You have a bit of a choice,
depending on how many vehicles
you have, is how far apart
you want the vehicles to be.
Because the idea is that
your lead vehicle is going
to be sufficiently far in
front of whatever it is
that you're protecting the
main body of the convoy.
So with only three vehicles,
you're kind of limited
as to what you can do, but
your typical is going to be
maybe two up front, then the main asset,
and then one bringing up the rear.
Cannons are not common,
but they are a thing.
You can sometimes find
them mounted as experiments
on tanks as well, but
they're basically a waste
of space and weight, so you
don't see them on tanks.
In terms of a missile launcher,
yeah, missile launchers on
armored cars are a thing.
This particular elevating
out of the 4-by-4 is
probably closer to a
BRDM anti-tank system,
but that's actually for
anti-armor purposes,
not anti-aircraft.
But hey, I guess when
you're dealing with Batman,
anything goes.
I got nothing. Zero. Sorry. No.
The Germans appear to be
equipped with Pak 40s.
It was a very good anti-tank
gun, 7.5 cm caliber,
definitely a valid threat against an M4.
Anti-tank! H.E.! Traverse left.
Traverse left!
That was a doctrinal fire command.
Now, the reason I know this
is they actually sent me
the script for filming
it. But that is basically
alert, target, and command of execution
in abbreviated fire command.
The fire commands back in
World War II weren't quite
as regimented as they are today,
but the fundamentals are
actually still the same.
You have an argument.
Do you want to advance
over open ground as a whole platoon,
or do you want to bound in sections?
In this case, because of
the amount of infantry
that they're trying to provide cover for,
I can see perhaps why they
went as a full platoon on line.
But also, it's a very,
very open, long field,
so maybe it was necessary
for the entire platoon
to advance on line simply so
that they could see the target.
Another gun, who's got eyes on it?
Somebody's going to ask,
how can a Pak 40 miss
at such short range?
You'll be surprised what
stress is going to do to you.
So there have been
studies, and the reputation
of the 88 is such that it doesn't miss.
In reality, they're firing 20
rounds to get a single kill,
because the stress of combat
is such that it is not
calm and collected on a gunnery range
when you're doing scientific testing.
It's, "Oh God, I'm about to die."
Let's light them up. Let's
go. Let's clean it up.
Now, that scene is basically
why I became a tanker.
A line of tanks, every machine gun going.
A single tank is considered
to have firepower
more or less equivalent
to an infantry platoon,
because you have the
heavy machine gun up top,
you got a co-ax machine gun,
you got a bow machine gun,
and oh, by the way, you've got a cannon.
That is a lot of firepower
from a single vehicle,
and you can imagine this sheer suppression
and psychological effect
that comes of this,
let alone the lethal effects.
I know there were folks that didn't like
that I gave the last "Fury" a nine,
but I'm giving this one a nine as well.
I can't get elevation and he knows it.
So this was an actual
problem in Afghanistan,
and it's a mountainous
country, is that their tanks,
which were designed
really for open warfare
on the plains of Germany,
can't elevate high enough.
So what the Soviets ended
up doing was they developed
a variant of the ZSU-23-4
anti-aircraft gun,
the Shilka, called the Afghani.
So they would use those in conjunction
with the tanks to provide
that close-range, high-elevation security
that Daskal here is having a problem with.
The actual effect of hitting
the gun tube is not going to be
the petaling like you see
here. That's for visual effect.
What you're actually going
to get is a very small hole
that goes through the gun tube,
but it's still plenty bad enough
that you've disabled the gun.
The grenade will not have
separated the tracks,
so I must conclude it was the rocks,
but it's not impossible for rocky terrain
and maybe a less experienced
driver to angle his track
in such a way when he's turning
that he gets rocks caught
in between the wheels and the
tracks and snaps the track pin,
and that throws your track and loses it.
This scene is probably
a seven to an eight.
So out of the clips that we saw today,
if I had to recommend one
and one only to watch,
I'd probably go with "Band of Brothers,"
which is more of an infantry-related
show, but tanks work
with the infantry, and it's
always good to understand it.
Well, thanks for watching.
I hope you found it
interesting and informative.
If you want more the same sort of thing,
add one form, traverse right,
and click the video in that box.